Dean to his feet and here comes Bedard crowd on
its feet Bedard for Anthony to see you he scores
that's an overtime winner for the Hawks
long shift by Bedard but he makes a beautiful
saucer pass sees it happen to see who's got
some speed going wide it all starts in the
defensive Zone and you can see on the right
side of your screen there's nothing to see you
with that great stride of his he goes forehand
holds on for a second goes to the backhand
lifts it up but this is just a terrific pass
head man in the puck allowing athanasio
to skate into it and after will cranley's
made some good saves he can't get this
one here and there's the pass right on
the tape and a good hoister on the backhand
there by nothing to see you to win the game
Anthony seal at 20 goal season in his first with
the Hawks last year and a preseason game-winning
goal Connor Bedard picks up two assists in his
United Center debut address I'm going to see you
hockey's back pain and it's just good to play
that first game everyone in the league you're
chopping at the bit to get out there you
know teams like St Louis have played like
four more preseason games the the Blackhawks
have been doing everything they can to get
ready for these games now you get one under
your belt it's successful home debut for for
Conor Bedard and for I I mean I really think the
young players stepped up and played really well